Well, let's talk about climate change.
Now, people think, "Hey, aren't we getting the solar panels...
... and windmills to be a lot less expensive?
And isn't that helping reduce greenhouse gases"?
And the answer is, absolutely.
But, there's a lot more to do than just taking electricity to zero emissions.
There's a variety of things that generate greenhouse gases.
We have a lot of sectors of the economy, like manufacturing,...
...that are emitting greenhouse gases that aren't talked about as much.
Manufacturing.
Everything we make, even a cute little squishy like this,...
...that's emitting 21% of the greenhouse gases.
The number of buildings in the world is going to double by 2060.
It's like we're going to build a new New York City every month for the next 40 years.
It's a gigantic amount of materials.
Steel, cement, wood, all emitting greenhouse gases.
We're going to have to figure out how to make all these things in a different way.
And so, we're going to need a lot of change, a lot of innovation,...
...to bring the emissions from all those areas down to zero.